that how's everybody doing
kevin who said that uh
uh alice in peace right off the bat will
you give beth longo
uh birthday wishes i will give beth
longo anything she wants today's breath
longest birthday yes
[ __ ] bev longo got me a sweet ass uh uh
foul quarter luck dragon
that sits on my desk right now happy
birthday beth
i'll be seeing you in new jersey
i'm heading out to new jersey you are go
i know well i knew it was like
setting up movies pop-up is coming to
red bank we're not saying where yet but
red bank new jersey
uh mid-september and i'm gonna
not run drive out there so that i could
be there for the opening and then we're
going to throw like a
drive-in event out there same way we're
doing out here
on monday me and ralph garman doing
hollywood babylon
at uh the vineland drive-in and city of
industry go to seesmod.com for tickets
thank you thank you thank you blazing
pants
if this babylon show goes well guess
what show goes next
the 10th anniversary drive-in live show
of jay and silly bob getting old and
stuff so
um we'll be doing an event back east as
well
beth uh i will see you
at the movies pop-up happy birthday
she's amazing
sorry going oh good go bigs is in jersey
he's going too little bit
biggs is the one who gave us the box his
mom i love that box me and my wife been
studying that box
since i got it last week it sits on um
in our bedroom and the master bedroom
suite that's pretty much where we live
uh there's a big louis vuitton trunk old
trunk they steamer trunk
and on top of that is like you know
where you put your keys your [ __ ] the
pills that i take every day
it's like the room desk box is sitting
right there man it's beautiful it's got
all pictures from celebrity
show off and stuff um we lost celebrity
show off
last night um the final
episode of celebrity show-off happened
and uh it was
tori spelling uh who won the entire
competition uh but thank you all for
watching
sun and lockdown and voting it up all
that time
we uh i don't i don't quite understand
the math but
regardless it was fun to make the show
for like all summer long
jay got to be in it and yeah and you
guys are so sweet about watching it so
many many thanks uh my friends but tori
spelling
holds the pink belt man how did you feel
you were there
for the moment of the decision were you
like 9-0-2-1 oh
no uh oh
hype train oh [ __ ] trains are coming
already it's incoming so what this level
one is beginning
yeah so let's see where it's at we'll
tell you thank you for the uh for the
for the
subscription indy so already we're on
seventy percent level one oh [ __ ] it
just keeps
traveling man we're going up to we're at
oh my lord
it's about to leave level one all
together and bring us all together at
level two
you've done it i may have lost celebrity
show off but i
won level one yes yes now let's see if
we can get that hype train all the way
up to level five remember kevin's been
here we've not
uh not have not last time
last time we hit three levels but we
didn't hit five but we had ten thousand
people
watching later on so yeah this is this
we need to
hit level five or else i might leave
until he gets a second microphone
uh let's see what else is going on we
can answer questions
x player 555 says it's a wrap from tori
she wrapped me hard man
spelling counts nobody understood that
but i did
i'm cute even though i won even though i
was on more episodes than tori
uh somehow she won but congratulations
to torrey spelling uh her and her family
is very good
what is this monkey with a what yeah
someone came in with a
bunch of subs gifted subs what's that
name monkey what's up
it's on the minifeed this one here yes
monkey with spunk
gave you a bunch of [ __ ] man and level
two is complete
tenacious tv we were so busy doing our
post-mortem on
on tour spelling and celebrity show off
we didn't even notice
the hype train it always moves kids hype
train don't want to hear no bitching
hype train don't want to hear about how
tory spelling
took your title hype train always moving
kids
always moving forward ever forward
looking for the hype this is how i feel
about it i
of course wanted uh my head real life
mate to win
but i know you would it would have been
cool and awesome
but she actually was crying and it
seemed like her
family and stuff really appreciated it
oh and i wouldn't have
i might have cried if i won as well but
i'll never know
and that's true you would have but way
to start out he's like i like my boy
but the lady i don't know and never will
meet she cried so she should win
no it's saying that if anyone should
have no i don't think she should have
won but if anyone was to
to take it it would be her over everyone
else because my honest family was like
i honestly felt like um in terms of
sheer
talent on display yes oh my god
chaos king tv just gifted you with ten
yes baby not one not two not three
ten tier one [ __ ] subs chaos king
and they just took us all the way to the
hype train of level four i believe we're
on level four now
we're about to start level trying to
catch up it's trying to catch up
level three is complete bonanista said
remember two
top gifted subs why how come when is it
how do you make it scroll
uh you have to press or something no no
uh so yeah
sorry uh yeah make it live something oh
no it's sure so scroll
up to bonanista remember two
top two gifted suburbs for august get
special prizes is that true
yeah yeah well done bonanista something
that the guy whose show it is
he wasn't even thinking about he's too
[ __ ] famous for that
no no he's like the [ __ ] pewdiepie of
this [ __ ] he don't care about nothing
except playing his games making that i
know that's not true
i'm trying to i'm trying to know that's
not it just keeps moving and we're
congratulating everyone but yes
anyone who's in here right now the top
gifter gets a bunch of free stuff and
there's a command that if you put in
gifter
and the command is jay touch me
watch this jay touch me cuckoo
type [ __ ] touch me there you go yeah i
was thinking other things i was like
dirty we got kids in the audience see he
touched me uh level four of the hype
train ladies and gentlemen we're at 61
with three minutes three and a half
minutes to go i think it's safe to
assume
we may see the hype train ride into
level five
oh will wilkins what will wilkins do
he's just there saying go go go go go go
indeed he no gifts of tears put your
[ __ ] [ __ ] in
yeah where's your tier one subs will
wilkins
why don't you get that boss of yours to
pay you more so you can pay him more
technically you're his boss so you
better pay him more so he can give you
some tier one subs
[ __ ] 65 79 80.
will wilkins just give it will wilkins
was bullied
into gifting five tier one subs well
done
sir thank you way to buckle to a guy who
already has too much look around us for
heaven's sake
what we need to do on this hype train is
take [ __ ] away from jay
no yeah like these toys they go to this
person these figures go here
we're gonna do that after uh will
wilkins though just got us up to
level five level five there it is
hundred percent
of level four hype train level five
begins
iceman right uh dallaway said kevin
you said once jay may have been an extra
in porn as a juror
been asking him for ages but he has been
judging the question you've never done
porn no no no
and if he did porn do you really think
he'd just be like a juror in the
background no i'm sure he'd be like
well whatever i can't oh oh no no oh my
god
we may have uncovered something here get
the hype train ready to go to porno town
what are you talking about you played a
juror in a porno no no no it wasn't in
the porno but no but you made me think
that i was out of porn once where they
were shooting
at uh but wait
dude breaking news kids this ought to
take us take us right to the hype
[ __ ] train level five what are you
talking about
so i gotta hear this i was
uh it's funny because i'm trying to
think there's a guy i know who was
a porn dude megan yeah he was making
points who i hung out with
many many moons ago um and i remember he
was
leaving a porn site and i think he was
doing something in a courtroom
thing will wilkins says he's going to
invoice for those memberships
oh will so wait were you in a porn or no
i was not in the but you were on a porn
set
yes did you see things uh i don't know
more importantly can you smell things on
a poor set porn set
uh like the aroma no no no i mean not
when i was there because again i was
like outside really waiting i i was
you were waiting while they were
shooting the point i believe i was going
to meet someone there to try to see if i
it was not in a good time i don't think
oh it was one of those it was in the bad
days
he couldn't even enjoy this damn porno
because it was in the sad bad i was like
vagina or drugs yeah see you later
vagina the heroine of the porn or heroin
in my arm
i think i'll go the letter uh those are
dark days and they're long gone man 53
chrissy god jokes says watching the
stream is the highlight of my day why
thank you christie oh big chaos king tv
says much love everyone kevin thanks for
inspiring me to get into film work
appreciate everything
you and the godly mr muse godly
yeah he was out of porn said he didn't
even look
um let's see oh my lord pfinity thank
you thank you
where where everyone everyone that's
they're just nonsense the minifeed
is like where do you get to the bottom
of the minifigure is this you go yeah
yeah so
the last person that gifted a sub there
you go
layla gave you 100 bits thank you yes
you got a bunch of followers kendrell
gave you 100 bits
cheer 100 kevin can you tell everyone
the story about you
and your maroon underwear i used to wear
maroon underwear
uh that i went to the large guys tour
fat guy store
and i was always wearing like you know
tidy whiteies and [ __ ] one day i walked
in
and they had a pair of maroon underwear
and i bought them
and and called my wife and was just like
check it this out man i picked up maroon
underwear she's like why
and i was like because i make me look
like superman and she was like
it does not uh so i wore maroon
underwear for years uh and then one day
i replaced them with a black underwear
so i look like batman instead oh yeah uh
wait a sec sorry kids the hype train
is three percent three percent away from
pulling into the station
level five with a minute and a half to
go
man uh kev jay's been cheating on you
man since church 11 22. who are you
[ __ ] cheating on me with no what does
that mean in what way in what sense
it don't matter because the hype train
reached level five and all infidelities
are forgiven
yes look at this screw to cheating we
pulled into the station with level five
thank you ladies and gentlemen you got
us there man uh
boy oh boy now nothing will ever be bad
or wrong again
good time now that we've gotten our hype
train settled the way
uh we got some boxes that we can open
for you today kids
on jay and sound bob get twitchy we're
gonna do what's in the box
because we got uh one two three four
five five it looks like
five boxes of stuff to open up
good yes we'll wait till we're like a
thousand viewers and then we'll start
cracking open stuff meanwhile
until then we'll answer questions kev
any video game appearances to look
forward to you as a playable character
in call of duty was fun
it says aqua befells um thank you of
course there's jane sullenbob mall brawl
if you're into 8-bit side scrollers uh i
am i play it all the time he gave me the
nintendo switch for my birthday
so last night before i went to bed i was
playing donkey kong sleep playing donkey
kong
sorry my friend uh one of the guys the
friend you're cheating on me with
yeah and the guy who did the like j and
bob what's in the box logo the logo yeah
in three hours he showed me clips of all
the things
and at the end is amazing i don't even
want to spoil it teach us how
i know i told him i was like there's no
way you got past i can't i can't beat my
own game
just like i can't win in my own life i
can't win at my own game
um bonanista says it's ash wednesday all
is forgiven
you know what the brag found found just
writes in there no it wasn't three hours
it was an hour and 20 minutes
come on bro really i've been working on
it for weeks
i'm still can't get past swayze man guys
hold on i'm gonna it's gonna tell us in
a minute
uh how many uh like what the what the
hype train was in total so i'm gonna
tell you oh why didn't it do that
what do you mean it usually says like
your support is strong you got such and
such and such and such
and it gives you like a a total of
gifted subs and bits and i just wanted
to say thank you but
it didn't tell me [ __ ] found to be
missing did the shopping carts in one
board they said yes oh my god this is
lit and i've not been on
forever but 10 months on here who got
the blunts
boy the messages are going thick and
fast
um yay dude i saw your panel with bill
and ted
face the music it was a great panel for
comic-con oh you know what's gonna be
great
fandom coming up fandom dc fandom
they're gonna show trailers for the new
batman movie by matt reeves they're
gonna show wonder woman 84 trailer
they're going to show a trailer for the
suicide squad
game oh it's going to be amazing that's
next weekend i think
uh let's see kev any tips for current
fat ass become a former fat ass
said uh groovy mr drizzle
i'm not saying to do this but i went
vegan and it worked for me and here's
why i [ __ ] hate vegetables
so given a choice between eating
vegetables and very little
i choose very little so by virtue of
that your weight
kind of comes down and when you do eat
since it's plant-based it's good for you
it's not like filling your body up with
crap and stuff so
vegan i'm not telling you to do it and
[ __ ] i'm not trying to trigger anybody
but [ __ ] sometimes you're like
go vegan or
i went vegan they're like well [ __ ] you
i'm eating 10 times as much meat now
and then they're like all right i have
fun but that that's what worked for me
and i walk a lot i didn't hike today
normally i've been getting up every
morning
hiking at eight in the morning because
it's been [ __ ] hot in los angeles
all last week and all this week it's bad
i just came in the days it was 100
degrees outside
so this morning i got up at eight and i
opened up the door
and got hit with an oppressive wave of
heat so i'm like [ __ ] it i'm gonna walk
i'm gonna hike runyon tonight
so i'm gonna go tonight when it's dark
um high running canyon but
i've added that a little bit of exercise
every day
excuse me you don't have to hike running
canyon but that's the one i do um
hello uh jill sorry someone said say hi
to my wife jill what up jill
what up jill um not to be insensitive
but here in norcal it's definitely ash
wednesday
yeah okay thank you profinity uh and
everybody who gifted subs uh everyone
who gave bits thank you guys very very
much the bits givers the sub givers you
are the true heroes sorry all the names
i can't get through all the names juicy
i tell everyone thanks for the uh
donation minnesota lg
i'm 22. he wrote uh look at the top
seeing the top minifeed
the minifeed right there a few seconds
uh minnesota lg has donated five
five bucks and i'm 22 and watched clerks
for the first time when i was 17 been a
fan ever since
and i'm now trying to become a filmmaker
you guys have been a great motivation to
me plus
i live by the mall rats mall in eaton
prairie oh the eden prairie mall in
minnesota
um well thank you for those kind words
minnesota large or lg if you will
um anybody could be a filmmaker man
nowadays particularly with like
this [ __ ] think about this we didn't
have this
when we started making movies a phone
that you could shoot a movie on it
looks so good well look at that tiny ass
[ __ ] dick camera
stick it in your [ __ ] crotch your
pants so you can be like chitchat
oh let me put it on my tripod exactly
man
so we didn't have all that high-tech
fancy stuff you kids got today
so you know even if you're not being
given access to some movie camera on
some movie set nobody's giving you
money to shoot a movie you still have
the ability thanks to your good old
phone
to shoot and practice and make films and
stuff
it's great time to be creative
technologically
okay uh scrapzilla said not to be
insensitive but it's definitely ash
wednesday
in californ northern california we've
had fires in the state
as you know california is a state that
periodically
twice a year three times a year
especially when it's hot goes on fire
but i think this one was
arson case if i remember reading
correctly somebody lit a fire and so
they've been all the firefighters first
responders been fighting so
our thanks to the good folks of
california who are putting their lives
on the line the first responders
uh for those of us so we can breathe
easy
and not worry about it we don't want to
go outside in the hot air you open the
door you hit with waves imagine putting
that suit on the fireman's suit
oh we are thank you guys utter i was
going to say [ __ ] but that's not
flattering because a [ __ ] is
magnificent we are utter dickholes
who couldn't even take the heat outside
let alone the heat that the firefighters
face when they go fight a blaze indoor
and outdoors so
we thank them um let's see what else we
got here
uh hugo jerry herrera
said uh and what about batman bella
cassidy
it would be good if it comes out and
they reissued the previous series
uh i'm with you but i mean we'll see
with this new shake up dc comics that
just happened
at the end of last week means for that
like they got rid of a lot of editorial
staff they're cutting a lot of books
yeah they're feeling the effects of
[ __ ] the coveted pinch and stuff and
so it's now trickling down
dc universe app has been more or less
shuttered because everything's on hbo
max
so i don't know if i walk in there now
and be like hey we want to finish comic
book where you started 10 years ago they
might be like go [ __ ] yourself
the world's on fire so uh that doesn't
mean i can't work on the book with walt
on the side so i just recently because i
did a
a uh shindig kind of event like this
with uh my
friends at that kevin smith club if you
ever want to hang out with me
solo join that kevinsmithclub.com so we
did a shindig thing and somebody asked
me about and i whipped out the folder
full of artwork
that walt did 10 [ __ ] years ago in my
scripts and stuff and was showing them
pages
show them that it's real so i left it on
my desk after that i was like you know
what i'm gonna leave this on my desk
because
maybe i should finish this so i will get
around to finishing it
soon however dc comics might be like
uh we're not doing that right now
although you know i think i can
guarantee them like i'll guarantee you
sales i can sell a comic book that's for
sure
maybe not a motion picture but i could
sell a comic book
um matt westfalen says did you ever get
the hellbob jerseys
yes i pitched the idea to quigly after
you said the phrase hellbob on hbo
but you never got the jerseys made for
the stash just the shirt which i have i
did
have a hellbob jersey and it's now in
the hands of uh
somebody who went to the james bob
reboot roadshow tour for the vips
people that bought the most expensive
ticket where they hung out with me and
jay
before the show or after the show
backstage i liquidated all of my black
jerseys my black jerseys and so i signed
them all and everybody that went vip
got to take home a jersey so the hell
bob is in in better hands than mine
right give your sandman picture
what's happening no i don't know if it's
uh yeah you keep talking sir i'm gonna
show you because i
think it's sandman picture sorry i
thought it was uh
a thing that we both got i uh i'll tell
you right now
uh i better get it that damn sandman
picture
um buff shaggy oh
69 says kev how parched are you and why
won't jay get you a drink i'm like i
know i'm about to
i know i'm so [ __ ] thirsty i'm like i
can't even
put words together i'm so dry parched um
he didn't ask that he asked uh really he
asked
where was that question oh he said
thanks so much for being one of the
biggest parts of my childhood
the other biggest part was the alien
franchise i'm currently showing my
girlfriend the series
do either of you love alien let me tell
you something buff shaggy 69
i love me some aliens aliens uh
second one i like daily what's that
[ __ ] man bro why so why are you sandman
because they did it for me because who's
they
this is dc comics yeah who did this i
can't tell you
i thought you got one too no what the
[ __ ] is this
i want that look at that jay as drawn in
dc comic style
in the bat cave and it says the sandman
none of this makes sense
i don't know dk did it oh i know what it
is because there's sandman as an audible
podcast
yes look at you man enough kisses get me
a drink
i'm going i'm gone to take your phone
out
if you didn't take that phone i would
have been surfing through it for dick
pics going look at this
whatever something cold though i'm so
[ __ ] parched
um all right now that he's gone we've
got a few minutes alone um
let's get to what you cats want to know
chaos black ninja says kevin can wait he
sure can
he'd been waiting for a long time um
ori lilu said i used to work at the eden
prairie mall in minnesota
that's when i fell in love with your
movies thank you oh my god i love that
mall
i went to it within the last year while
we were touring jay and samba reboot
during the reboot rocha tour i believe i
popped in at the mall
but yeah it's different now they took
down the palm trees and stuff it still
is my mall it'll always be the mall red
small
um let me see slipstream first says
we're building the film industry in our
hometown
good for you well done film industries
everywhere
i say um kevin you were looking [ __ ]
handsome on celebrity show off says
onslaught 69
66 why thank you um yeah man what an
easy job that was they would shoot it in
my office
so i literally rolled out of bed and put
on a jacket
underneath i was just wearing shorts and
[ __ ] i mean not jean shorts like i do
when i'm out but just like
my sit around the house shorts so
what a fun gig what a fun summer job
that was man good times all around
uh danny huckin says hey kev what's
going on i met you at the hartford stop
the reboot roadshow tour
waited almost two hours outside you took
my fiancee's phone and took selfies with
us
and i told you about my podcast and that
we have three kids and you asked me how
i have time to be creative
what's up how are you that was all
before covid
we couldn't even have this conversation
in the coveted world right after the
show
be masks and like stand back he can't
get the disease he's for the virus he's
[ __ ] in a high-risk category they put
me in a high-risk category because my
stupid heart attack
but um i have vague memories danny
huckins
of uh of of uh being there in uh
hotfood home of the whale if you will
uh let's see what else we got
it's over a thousand says rando
calrissian 37
well remembered rando so as soon as the
other rando
the one i stand next to in movies and
stuff as soon as that rando returns
we'll start knifing boxes and opening
them up and seeing what's inside it's
gonna be good
times man good times dr acula tv
dr acula that's suspicious
um dracula tv says what's your next
project
i'm not sure we got this movie called
kilroy was here that there's a trailer
out for
um that we made not too long ago for
well
it was a little while ago we were making
it before i had my heart attack
and then uh after i had my heart attack
we shot more
and then uh we went and shot jay and sam
bob reboot
and now you know we finished the tour
and got home and they were like stay
inside
copenhagen and we were like ooh let's
finish kill
so uh we'll be probably taking that out
thank you look at all these drinks i got
drinks
for days he really he's gonna hydrate my
my dry mouth
um next immediate project hollywood
babylon
10th anniversary show live at the
vineland drive-in
in the city of industry go to csmod.com
tickets if you want to see me and ralph
doing hollywood bob babylon on the big
drive-in screen
oh it's gonna be fun this is like my
birthday show except not a movie
but babylon
i can't tell you how [ __ ] refreshing
that was um
beyond that uh i guess i'm you know
right now i'm working on
masters of the universe which is turning
out phenomenally thanks to good folks at
uh powerhouse animation oh
my lord it's wonderful uh mall rats 2
is in looking like 2021 clearly not
going to be in 2020.
uh script is i mean the second draft of
the script
uh love the story um
i think it's it's an incredibly worthy
follow-up to mall rats because by the
time we make it it's going to be a
sequel
21 years later um it's a lot of time
between movies but it turned out
wonderful so hopefully that will be one
of the next things
i'm working on green hornet right now
which we start taking out at the end of
august and pitching um you know
uh and then there's something else i'm
working on which i haven't talked about
yet
uh but yeah there's a bunch just enough
stuff to stay
busy and then i'm heading out to jersey
uh for the opening and the movies pop-up
in red bank new jersey
so yeah there's some stuff on the
horizon
uh you know just nothing like
not like the big sexy like we're making
a movie we don't know when we're doing
that
uh we're but we're gearing up for it
getting ready
they're shooting down at the parking lot
down the street from us are they
yeah they're shooting something called
yeah i don't know it said something like
spoof
tkbs james please show the discord
message to kevin it'll take two seconds
it's important you want this fortnight
[ __ ] to happen
what is that okay what's that all about
i don't know let's see
fortnite message from tk
p1 data
that's some good cold water son
so what is this yeah this is the message
you said
oh regarding official character request
on behalf of american actors fortnite
colby duke says yeah if kevin is
interested in participating as well
it'd be best if jason can oh see him
on the e c him on the email to add or
provide contact information
thanks i don't know what that all means
yeah i think they're just saying if you
because i
emailed them and maybe they're like
jmu's email sucks so cece kevin let him
talk to him email who but it's the the
epic people from fortnite
and they'll make us playable characters
oh he got me something
but there's the fruity though oh thank
you there's the grab that box on top
so you can try oh okay um can you grab
that box i'm gonna show these kids
i don't know if i can right it's what's
the idea of
yeah we're not smoking or anything but
it's just it was we got this smoking
device that they made
that i don't i uh it's a glass blunt and
i don't quite understand
how it works um so this is one this is
what it looks like
and it's made of two glass pieces one
pulls out and puts into the other
now they have glass blunts i've seen
where this part of the device
is a screw so you're supposed to pack
this with weed and then you screw it in
and then there's room and it heats the
weed and that's what you're smoking or
whatever
but we cannot for the life of us figure
out look at that cool ass design
figure out how it works so i've been
trying at home for the last two days
so i brought them over to jordan jason's
wife to be like can you find somebody
smart enough
to make this work um
and of course i was wearing my
j and silent bob mask ladies and
gentlemen
if you go to amazon.com
where they sell stuff like this um so
wait
you could be a playable character in
fortnite so it sounds i don't think so
bro i think like they're doing thor now
i saw like chris hemsworth thor they're
not gonna do [ __ ] the likes of us
they're doing they're doing a bunch of
stuff butt nuts
again they have a bunch of other people
too marshmallow
they're doing no but he's famous we're
not famous uh but no the email got the
guy from epic is saying for us to write
him so we'll write him thank you tkbs
for reaching he's from epic
uh tkbs is not from epic but he knew an
email for epic
and he they said have him read it
bona nista says bay area san francisco
we had 24 hours of lightning strikes
we've got fires from all directions
right now sky
is gray ash is real
wow wow wow man yeah california is
burning unfortunately right now
not right where we are thank heavens but
sadly in a lot of other places
i read some places there's some town i
think it's in germany or some sort of
[ __ ] they got like a chocolate factory
and there's a backup in their smoke
stacks so
it exploded chocolate dust covered the
whole town
and you can literally be like everyone's
yeah i would have been like
wait is it vegan i don't care and i'll
be eating it and stuff i think this guy
wrote again danny hopkins danny huckin
says hey kev what's going on i meant no
it was the same one we did it oh you did
okay
nice dude um danny hopkins reminds me of
danny hookshin
which reminds me of danny hudson old
friend of mine keeps writing it oh so
you got you got that yeah yeah okay
so it keeps repeating it's tough well no
it's because the chat see if i go too
fast
then it puts you back up i know they
they should i'm not
uh what happens if you click chat just
out of curiosity
no this went down yeah would it put you
at the bottom no
they should really they should that that
should be a thing where you just press a
button and it takes you to the absolute
bottom as opposed to whenever jay
scrolls down
when you get to the bottom it just
immediately jumps up these are first
world problems
but now we're caught up when we're live
did you read the article on the boy who
saved his sister from a moose attack
using video game moves says beth longo
number one happy birthday beth number
two what
i didn't read that not me neither moose
is one of the second most
dangerous animal to man in the entire
animal kingdom
uh number one hippopotamus lethal
to man hate men and women presumably
uh they'll they'll [ __ ] with you in a
heartbeat hippos man and they're [ __ ]
killers
nobody knows that because of that
[ __ ] game hungry hungry hippos
they're like god eat marbles [ __ ]
they eat [ __ ]
human brains and [ __ ] so hippos [ __ ]
with humans
next one down of animals the giant
animals that [ __ ] with humans
not a bear [ __ ] moose most dangerous
second most dangerous animal to man and
they made goofy cartoons about one
called bullwinkle
they completely completely changed the
image of the moose man but the moose is
a fearsome killer
his eyes he kills his eyes they roll
over white
that's my captain quinn all right what
else we got boxes
yeah let's do it man what we do
periodically on this show ladies and
gentlemen
jay and sam bob get twitchy um is uh
sometimes we play games
sometimes we sing sometimes we open
boxes and today is one of those open
boxes kinds of day
the good folks at mattel
the toy company um who employ me
to make the masters of the universe
cartoon for netflix which you'll be
seeing next year
have sent us um boxes of toys to open so
we're gonna open those toys here
if uh if you're lucky you might win one
of these toys what what is what do they
got to do
play marbles we'll play marbles
afterwards so we're going to unbox a
bunch of toys
and then jay will play marbles with you
later on
and give out the choice do you actually
send out the toys and stuff that
yeah yeah so yeah let me see let me see
my feedback in the chat room
how many people have ever received their
stuff from jay the freebie stuff that
that he opens and [ __ ] like that um
minnesota lg says i've had terrible luck
recently hope it turns around with these
giveaways
yeah man minnesota lg gotta win a marble
game dude
terrible luck they've been having um jay
doggers subscribed to tier
one they've subscribed for four months
dude yes
i got an iron bob funko pop it's awesome
says gaceroni aren't they
oh they're so sweet iron bob funko pops
man very very cool
um all right shall we do it
yes i got the adam west bus from j muse
i've never won anything
from yet from jay but i really want to
i'm still waiting on the hound head trey
mock didn't get his hound head you [ __ ]
that was a month ago i got two things
from jason
the clap and herpes now no
they're stepping these people waiting
don't get me wrong you got to get on it
you got to get an assistant like julian
and julian will send it or luke oh
that's right luke quentin got married
yeah that's the only that's why you
don't got your hound head because luke
who sends out jay's stuff
he selfishly went and got married no we
love luke and we're glad he's married
happy
happy camper he is but anyway he went
off and got married so he'll be back
soon then he'll send your [ __ ] out
can you imagine the dude's like i've
changed my life i've bound my life to
another human being for all eternity
it's the most sacred thing
a human being could do and then
someone's like send out my [ __ ] hound
head
he's like i guess um our daughter
what the oh my lord what's this this is
sad
i think squat box says our daughter is
in end of life care and covet has left
us stuck inside
oh my god i'm so sorry the reboot was
just the bit of schnoogies we needed
thanks for inspiring us to keep creating
content
spoiled rotten 79 and i would love to
connect with you all squat boxing
spoiled rotten 79.
my god my heart goes out to you man
thank you for the common words
send them something here
love give me my wallet send them a
goddamn something we'll send you
something
uh it ain't gonna make everything better
but it might make things for a second or
two be like ah maybe things aren't as
bleak but you're right
keep creating man we create things
that's the antithesis
of destruction so making things whenever
i sit around i feel like man logan
life blows we all feel like that even
when your life is great
it's important to take your mind off
that track rearrange it completely
one of the best ways to do that i find
is to just be creative instead of
reading the news sometimes i'll read the
news and be like
look at all these people [ __ ] doing
better than me what's my problem
well and then i start and then i'm like
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] whiny [ __ ]
don't think about that just sit down and
start making a thing and so
once i get creative it takes all the
negativity away so it's important to be
creative particularly world legos
world's at its bleakest that's right you
can be creative by building legos and
[ __ ] like that
if you're like this cat or if you're
like me you like to write and stuff
all right man who says hey kevin and
jason i would like to wish to my best
great director good luck with this new
event
he's going to have this next monday with
his friend ralph you did great work in
the last live
of yesterday i'm glad to see you and i
have to go to sleep before that i want
to say
good night to you both manu i saw your
pages at the beach
banyo look like you were having a good
time my friend
on instagram um spit that out again
because you did that in the beginning
there's some more people here about your
event with
uh ralph that's right man you in
california
you want to go to a drive-in and watch a
live podcast me and ralph are
celebrating 10
years of hollywood babylon at the
vineland drive-in
on monday tickets at
seasmod.comsesod.com
um we're going to do hollywood babylon
but you know out of driving projected
huge everyone's going to be in their
cars
honking horns and [ __ ] it's going to be
like my driving birthday party it was
fun
this thing goes smooth and well the next
live
show is the 10-year anniversary of jay
and silent bob get old that's right
that's right man it's gonna be a good
ass time so if you want tickets
see me and ralph seesmod.com is the key
um all right traymock says i volunteer
to live in a tent
in the backyard done
you can live here my friend traymark
apparently he needs somebody to mail
[ __ ] out like your hound head
so well i didn't want to look he already
got his pop that was ruined
he he already got his uh movies that was
ruined treymark
is the one who got the bob was ruined
when he got it finally and same with his
uh movies so i didn't want to send this
because i'm waiting till you get those
and send out new good luck otherwise the
hound head would have been broken
good point look at that look at that he
talked his way out of that [ __ ]
pickle didn't he
um all right shall we you got is that a
knife that's a knife it's a boot knife
how about i slide over here and we slide
you in here
jay's got a boot here put the table this
way you know pointing into the
into the end you really need a cup
holder here no
well for now i mean just very wow it
screwed the [ __ ] up
all right here we go ladies and
gentlemen look at this we got one we got
two we got three
four five boxes from the good folks at
where
mattel so jay has a knife
uh he has used the knife his knife
should be used
and he has stuck them in the box and he
has opened that box and now we get to
see inside
jay what's in the box
all right kids this is the masses of the
universe retro play
line modern posing retro place there's
more points of articulation than the
original figures they put out
but they look like the classic figures
and of course
this is duncan himself man at arms the
most
dangerous man in eternia ladies and
gentlemen
um he looks like his classic incarnation
and his little
little book in there yeah hell yeah
there's a little book beast barrage is
the comic you're gonna get
um new for 2020.
yeah that looks awesome all right so we
got a man at arms ladies and gentlemen
who else we got of course man there he
is
the beast man ladies and gentlemen uh
dreaded enforcer of skeletor
a savage henchman if you will uh there
he is man
uh he comes with a mini boat in a mini
comic as well
also the retro play version of the
figures which have been getting
very strong positive reviews online a
lot of people like i didn't think i'd
like these so much but i love them
uh evil lynn the evil warrior
goddess um look at that ladies and
gentlemen
look at her uh she is one of our main
characters in my master's in the
universe
revelations series for netflix man
uh naturally you know since she was
skeletor's second in command she plays a
big part
uh in our series and there she is with
all the points of articulation
she's bad ladies and gentlemen she's bad
it's ladies night
yeah when you got a bad lady you need a
good lady and that good lady
is tila that's right heroic warrior
goddess they called it when she came out
this is uh she her job as
captain of the guard was to protect adam
but she didn't know that adam was
really he-man so she kind of like a
fighty lois lane in the he-man mythos
and whatnot
her own uh agency and always has
had her own agency uh since the
beginning man in every episode
of he-man in the master's universe so
naturally she gotta be
right here for us um okay
there he is man here's our hero
the titular man of the hour e
man he man look at that man
look at the articulation look at the
power
look at it all man it's just he-man and
he's retro as a [ __ ]
um he's our hero prince adam uh
becomes he-man uh
spoilers if you didn't know that when he
raises the sword of power
the power sword and says the magic words
by the power of grayskull i
have the power
all right there's three of those so
we're gonna be able to give away three
of these
that's right man so a bunch of people
could get he-mans you get he-manned
like a [ __ ] because jay is gonna
send it to
some lucky lucky winners this mic keeps
falling
everybody's favorite evil lord of
destruction ladies and gentlemen
skeletor himself holding the havoc staff
uh the source of his evil powers well
not the source but his
almost like his magic wand and [ __ ] he
uses it blast people and whatnot
um look at one of the greatest bad guys
ever created skeletor himself known
throughout the world
and now voiced by the great mark hamill
used to be voiced by the great alan
oppenheimer and alan oppenheimer
who was the voice of skeletor is in our
masters of the universe
colon revelation series playing
the voice of moss man and it's a
wonderful performance man
um but here his his his main
performance his whole career right there
in he-man massive universe
skeletor now alan oppenheimer and mark
hamill
are voicing the lord of destruction
there's three of those and look at this
oh there's three skeletors
what is this uh they're minifigs
oh look at this kids look at this man
it's a box this [ __ ] thing
it's a box that looks like castle gray
skull
and inside we got these little
let's see
it's a mini castle gray skull eternium
minis they're called
and inside you could get either
he-man man at arms buzz off
ram man skeletor the horde
zombie he-man trap jaw
or jitsu man look at that full
collection on that side that was nice so
why you were saying
i know you could see it both sides look
at this [ __ ] that's a dope looking
castle grey skull man
and that's just the case and inside
should we open it guys yeah it's a
surprise it's just fun because not only
let's open it you get it oh here we go
yeah you got your boot knife kids
we're opening up castle grayskull to see
the secrets
that lie inside fabulous magical powers
were revealed to me the day i
raised my magic sword and said the way i
the day i raised my sword and said the
magic words
by the power of grace goal uh let's open
this bad boy up man
so easy in the open and then look who we
got
yeah and him got him power sword inside
that's awesome man a little book right
yeah a little comic and stuff oh that's
dope
all right man a lot of these to give
away yeah we've got a whole box so
well it looks like they tell you on the
bottom
no they don't but let's see if we can do
some basic math
a lot yeah that's what there's a bunch
in here so
everyone sign up jay's gonna send you
not everyone but as many people as you
can he's gonna send you
this mini castle grace call with uh
eternium minis inside
mini itunes the big box
it looks like there's uh i don't want to
open it all up because it looks like
there's uh oh maybe it's the same thing
but there's three of them
sorry oh there is okay
check it out man there it is so this is
rare they never do
prince adam or they don't do them as
much as they should
and there's prince adam um and the sky
the prince adam skysled man so check you
out
when his friends are in danger prince
adam leaps into the sky sled
and flies to the rescue um well not in
my experience when his friends are in
danger he raises his power sword
and he becomes he-man but how awesome
that they did a prince adam figure
that's that's kind of rare man they
they usually leave him off in favor of
doing he-man which is crazy because
it's the same body they just make them
you know a new paint for it but
look they did it man this also comes
with um
a sky sled but you could also get a
separate play set look at all the boxes
in case
because look there's a battle cap yeah
uh so yeah there's three there's three
sky sleds all right kids so jay
is gonna send you one of three sky sleds
unless i take one home but i probably
won't because
let you guys get it i bet you i could
probably get my own stuff from mattel
and
next year mattel making masters universe
revelations figures figures
based on on our series like based
with the designs looking like the
powerhouse animation designs and stuff
oh in the castle hopefully they'll come
out with the castle bro big ass
grayskull
uh was that everything uh yeah so that
was uh
yes because that thing's over there is
yeah so there it is folks
mattel nice we thank the good folks at
mattel
for bringing us a bunch of [ __ ] to open
and play with
um and show you all and now the
important thing is getting it into your
hands
how do they do this play the marble game
so later on when the marble game happens
to walk away with some of that sweet ass
mattel
masters of the universe uh swag
if you will meantime i'll pull over here
so you can get back over here
all right i could see it there we go now
we take our knife
and we played a knifey game where we go
between our fingers like in
aliens remember somebody was asking me
about alien
i like alien i like all the alien movies
but i love aliens
i i've so i remember paying to see that
in a theater with my own money
summer of 86 man and my ex-girlfriend uh
her brother
like i was saying like i think it's
gonna be a big hit and he was like no
it's not
and then it was a big hit and at the end
of summer i was like remember i said it
was going to be a big hit and he's like
i don't care
and i learned a lesson yeah i learned a
lesson that you can't rub the [ __ ] in
people's faces they don't want to hear
it
um what happened to manny faces says ks
black ninja 97 he's gone yeah where is
manny faces
um bona nissa says k
j is their uh show kev fall guys i've
seen it
you have now yeah i've seen is adorable
somebody was just trending on twitter
for he got it and it was because of that
he did it it said
oh was it tim was it tim tim the tatman
is that who did it anybody they probably
know it was
it was yup he beat the he beat the game
he's been trying to win it for like
weeks and it's funny because a lot of
these streamers are like really good at
fortnight great
duty but they weren't good at this yeah
they just couldn't it's really hard
right it's like luck well it seems hard
but then i have like a buddy who's won
20 25 times okay anyway but i haven't
won either i've been playing i played
monday i played for six hours last night
i played for
five hours and i still haven't got the
crown yet this guy tim the tatman
he was having the same issue but i guess
he finally got it he get i guess he beat
it because he was all over twitter
people were like he did it he damn did
it
so that seemed like fruity one if you
don't want that true i have jordan
brought a plane no i'm kidding this is
beautiful
it's not so easy cheers meow thank you
for that
uh it's i've gotten to the to the final
so many times and i always
thousands oh no of course thousands of
people have one
but it's a no way frozen fury really
you should read when you say you should
read what they said because when you're
like no way
everyone else is like what did you say
he said uh he said he won his very first
time frozen fury said i won my first
time
no way frozen fury
um jay and kevin where are you all gonna
make an appearance close
to the alabama coast floor obama maybe
somewhere in between the two um i don't
know
as soon as they let us go back out and
do shows and whatnot
easy to do drive-ins around here because
we live here and stuff but if this goes
well
conceivably kilroy if we tour that the
drive-ins cross-country
we'll be sitting together in a mobile
drive-in watching
kilroy kill floridians because the whole
movie's set in florida yeah we watched
the trailer the other day it's awesome
yeah jay's in it too yeah um
fall guys zom zombie idiot says fall
guys is basically
mxc what is that i have no idea
old man did you guys see the solo deep
fake with harrison ford and billy d
oh wilder oh said yes i did did you see
it they took a scene from
solo that had a different boy playing
uh han solo in that solo movie but they
deep fake that's where they take an
image of somebody and put it on top of
an image
so they took harrison ford's face and
stuck it on
that actor's face and it literally
looked like young harrison ford like a
shorter younger harrison ford
playing a guy it was incredible mxc says
text back
his japanese game show that's kind of
like wipeout
oh okay oh most extreme elimination
challenge
mxc i see thank you says jmu's most
extreme challenge it's a japanese game
show that some white guys re-dubbed oh
interesting
yeah mike sparrow 87 says we're in stage
three up north coming
to film moose jaws soon first i gotta
get a little money
gotta find that money then i'll be there
to make moose jaws
hey hey baby i got your money
hey moose jaws baby i got your money
no i said sorry someone just said they
had your underwear was
cracking up for days i agree though with
the the doctor about your underwear
oh thank you thank you victorian 1064.
yes that was from the uh what was it
silent but deadly
show that uh is out on video i think you
could watch it on amazon it was a
showtime special but
that was the show we were shooting the
night that i had my heart attack and
stuff
we were supposed to shoot two shows back
to back but we shot one show because
after the first show i was like
geek no i didn't even i didn't even do
that i didn't know i was having a heart
attack it was so [ __ ] subtle and
because i just [ __ ] them yeah i [ __ ]
maroon so it blended right in with my
[ __ ] shorts
um jason got to the hospital and he was
like i was
you gotta [ __ ] save them
he don't [ __ ] cry for nothing i cried
at the drop of a hat man i cry when the
flash like
saved somebody's life on the tv show i'm
like he's such a good boy
but jason don't really cry for anything
so when he got upset
when my heart's like i knew that [ __ ]
was serious and whenever he talks about
it gets quiet he's like oh we'll talk
about it
even though i didn't die i lived my
kid's the same way
she's like you can't talk you can't make
jokes about that i was like what am i
supposed to do
like [ __ ] that's all i do is make
jokes about everything um
and somebody like uh like in her
comments said something about
like she's you know harley put up a
picture and she's 21. my kid's 21 she's
a goddamn adult but she put up a picture
of her wearing like
not not like skimpy outfit but skimpier
than usual or whatever
and somebody was like you're gonna give
your father a heart attack and she wrote
a whole
like post about it yeah she's like don't
[ __ ] say that because you don't know
what it means the day you had a heart
attack i almost died myself and [ __ ]
she takes it real seriously um
any chance raffles says any chance of
james on bob cameo in the cw
arrowverse well we already did we were
in an episode of
uh flash playing a couple security
guards together
jay was in my first episode of flash
that i directed
when he came out the restaurant with the
humvee and he's like that's my mom's car
and then he was directed by supergirl
herself
when melissa benoist directed an episode
of supergirl last season and jay played
what a farmer
yeah it was awesome he's been up he's
been all up in the arrowverse
question is when they gonna give us our
own arrowverse show
like [ __ ] a booster gold and blue
beetle
yes i mean we're probably too old for
that we could be better version you know
who we could be
you know who he could definitely be
don't worry about me you know who he
could definitely be on a show
a joe west type see what i'm saying
like joe west is the grown-up in the
flash and [ __ ]
his surrogate dad you're old now so you
can't be the [ __ ] hero but you could
be
the hero surrogate detective yes or the
guy
the man in the chair old man in the
chair very old man in the chair
cw shows they don't really put people
our age on it but you could be a
detective joe west
and he would love that i i honestly i
wish i could get a cw
show like for for good like a permanent
show
just so i could cast a minute because he
[ __ ] loves those shows so much
um and i always tell people like you
should cast jay
and sometimes it do and sometimes i
don't if i had my own show
you would be my detective joe west
snake eyes o27 says kevin you and jay
could be on pennyworth
do you ever see that that's the alfred
show no no
yeah i'll take it if we could be on it
but we could be up anywhere they mean
because it's all
old people and [ __ ] well it's young
alfred it's the adventures of young
alfred and [ __ ] but
we need to we need you on a cw show i
like it
i like the ideas yeah i can't believe i
haven't seen pennyworth
it's not on cw i don't know what network
is on but it's about the adventures of
young alfred when he was like a
government spy so it's it's like
30 years before batman back when he was
like a young
[ __ ] he's not even a butler yet he
ain't no butler
son he's secret service special ssi or
some mi6 or whatever like british cia
to do how would you know it's called
pennyworth his name is alfred
that's the only way you know and then i
i don't know i haven't watched it but
maybe he
you know maybe they end the series with
him getting a job at wayne manor or some
[ __ ]
but i think this is before all that
before way before you know he meets the
wayne
it's on epics yeah yeah but cool idea
for a show
i'm just gonna pour this in here someone
said you should double as
alfred for alfred who you i think they
said that
double o alfred that'd be cool if you
played it out
a newfangled alfred where he's like come
on bruce
i want to play the marble game
and meanwhile [ __ ] gotham is on fire
oh someone said he meets batman's father
in the first episode
he meets thomas wayne yeah maybe he
saves his life oh
no [ __ ] thank god somebody watching
they will be talking about season two of
pennyworth or season three
at uh dc fandom i saw
um get that email done
j muse and kevin that's from your guys
yeah who wants you to be in the fortnite
game yes sir
there you go jay on star girl as a
retired hero
i would love i mean you're a bad guy but
come on like every [ __ ] week
he could be on yeah i love it it's good
it's good every week
it could be on a [ __ ] show and people
be like oh that's [ __ ] jay from
jane silenbob and he's oh that's jay
from twitch
like you carry your own audience they're
stupid not to cast you it dr
fade i love it makes me mad sometimes
honestly
the uh the [ __ ] uh the episode where
they go to
take down uh what's the one dude's name
the guy with the mustache who's like the
hacker
the gambler and and then in star girl
yeah i haven't got i'm halfway through
dude i hear the season finale it's
wonderful
i didn't see that yet but the taskmaster
master there's another task master
uh no is it say what is it
yeah dangle watch says both of you and
the boys would be epic
i agree they asked me to come be in the
boys season two
but i couldn't do it we were doing some
jane sullen bob thing and now season two
is about to air and i'm like
damn it's master thank you sports master
and then you know who the
the the the janitor is right from
episode one i s
i told matt westfield and i go watch the
janitor
is going to be somebody and that janitor
wasn't yeah
does anyone know who the janitor is i
don't want to spoil it
bruce wayne and batman beyond
the boys [ __ ] rocks ccw is putting uh
dc
swamp thing on in october yes they are
they're rerunning it hopefully it gets a
big enough reaction they do season two
justin uh the night just in the night
yep
janitor is justin the night jensen
echols is supposed to be in season three
of the boys he's your boy from uh oh
yeah
you love that show what is it
supernatural they're coming to an end
soon
kevin we're a small group of filmmakers
and working on youtube horror series the
columbia
minnesota police at missouri police
department maybe
m.o uh want us to stop because it's
scaring people
what would you do um you know put up
notices that are like
hey we're just shooting a movie so that
people don't get scared you wanna make
people nervous and stuff
until they're coming to watch your movie
but don't let you know i'm not saying
don't let the community stop you you
gotta be
uh courteous of the community because
you're shooting there and stuff
but as long as you put up filming
notices and whatnot you know and as long
as you're not shooting on other people's
property without permission
nobody can stop you from expressing
yourself for making your art and
if the reason is like you're scaring
people like we're making a horror movie
so yeah the idea is supposed to be scary
so
i mean again i'm not saying like [ __ ]
those people man you do what you want of
course you do what you want but within
reason
like you know if there are rules and
laws and [ __ ] you're shooting after
hours and
you're disturbing neighbors that ain't a
cool thing um but
you know if you're not hurt harming
anybody and you're
staying within the [ __ ] lines so to
speak and not you know being disruptive
there's no reason why you should have to
stop making your movie
you keep making it good sign though that
people like this is scaring me it's like
[ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] yeah we're trying to scare you ace
killer says move the mic closer to jay
yeah yeah i will when i talk next minute
why why is this all tight now oh because
i spun it
[Music]
you spin me right around
[ __ ] yeah get another mic
man it could be so simple uh let me see
get in season three of the boys uh i
mean maybe they tried once and since i
couldn't do it they're like [ __ ] him
and then they don't come back that's a
sad thing um
lieutenant carl ryback19 i think
says i loved your scene in daredevil
thank you my god i forgot about that
i was in a daredevil movie yes with with
uh
joey pants who's in the scene my
character was named jack kirby
uh cy76 says you guys get a chance to
check out
lovecraft country yet episode one was
really good i'm watching yet i'm away
till they're three apps and then dive in
um it's a new show on hbo looks badass
what did you call them
lovecraft country mobsters and stuff
like that
um i will be watching it soon i'm
currently
in engross deeply in uh
uh i may destroy you another hbo show
which has been
[ __ ] phenomenal i think their last
episode is next week
so i'm gonna let three lovecraft
countries gather up and then
binge binge binge three in a row because
i can't stand like the one at a time
that's why i stopped star girl i started
watching star girl i got to like
fight i waited till five episodes uh
that
and then uh after that
because if this thing is hitting it yeah
so we'd have to put it up it's good
um uh but yeah i waited for like uh
for a few episodes to to happen and then
i stopped to wait for more to catch up
it's all good guys i don't care i don't
mind the bikes right here because
kevin's only here once a week and
not even that because sometimes he's too
busy so if he talks for
an hour and a half straight on the mic
that's fine with me you know
so i still think it's all great
78 says i still think jay is kent nelson
still scared to put on the filming a
helmet of fate on
is he in star girl i didn't see i
haven't seen him i don't think
no because in the episodes i've watched
so far there's been no mention of
of dr fate that would be [ __ ] amazing
i love
dr fake kent nelson
nelson wait it's starting to bend
i hope that didn't yeah what's bender
uh sorry this i think because of this
like the way this
mount is that this well this is good
yeah as long as it's not as long as it's
stopped
why hello because it started to bend um
what else we got let's see scrolling
down
is it a d dez my fan says
is it the kevin smith
it's uh kevin smith i don't know about
the
there's a football player he seems to be
the kevin smith uh but yes i am
kevin smith um jay and sam bob have the
genesis power from preacher oh
if only swamp thing was canceled for
being
a toxic male says
blue eyed scorpio um i don't think
that's funny but because you know um
toxic but
i i don't think he was i think it was
canceled because it was too expensive
they finished their first season
and in order to uh put the swamp
set which they built inside a giant uh
soundstage in order to
put the the set to save the set
it was going to cost like a million or
more and you know
they made the decision like forget it
pull the plug too expensive
so now cw from what i understand is
going to run the old episodes that were
on dc universe
and if it catches on then you know maybe
they bring it back there
um i hope so because i loved alan moore
swamp thing when i was a kid
i loved all these things when i was a
kid but i don't always
watch them right away um so as much as
i'm like i'm phony as much as i'm like
oh i loved it as a kid
you know i can only catch up and [ __ ]
when i catch up with it like he was the
one
he's not here but he was hyping star
girl for me he's like you gotta watch it
it's [ __ ] amazing and so he he worked
he actually got me to watch it
um rafa live says kevin big fan from
canada
i'm a big fan of canada love you two
forever
two he ain't here [ __ ] that guy just me
now yeah i'll let him know that he you
love him as well he's a good dude
mike jacks are in stereo good to know
kevin help him lol i am trying um yo
kevin what do i got to do to get my
j and solo bob cartoon movie mug signed
by the both of you says 60 doughboy
um you bought one of those i love that
mug thank you so much
uh you see us we sign it it's that
simple or you can send it to jay
if he's got an address here and stuff he
does have an address if you send it here
we'll sign it and
luke will send it back when he's done
getting married
um groovy mr drizzle says what comic
book story arc would you give your left
nut to make into a motion picture kevin
100 creative control
no giant spider bs first off mr groovy
drizzle
uh mr or groovy mr drizzle i uh
would not want to make the movie myself
um i would ask for a role in
it um but the movie i would like to see
made of a comic book story line that i
adore well of course
um the dark knight returns and we got a
taste of it in
zack snyder's movies but a flat out
adaptation of the dark knight returns be
amazing
um i would do fearful symmetry um which
was a storyline
uh craven's last hunt a lot of people
know it as
such a great storyline or craven like uh
i think he shot spider-man but he buried
him alive
and then [ __ ] put on the spider suit
and went out pretending to be him great
story
i would do that uh there's a great comic
book i read years ago called kingdom of
the wicked
craven oh the [ __ ] there he is man
that's the book look at the back
the back is that's craven's last hunt
right there that's a great
great [ __ ] storyline he is rumored to
be the bad guy
in in the next spider-man movie which
some people
said is called homesick but i'm not sure
if it's called that or not but yeah
they're saying craven might be the bad
guy you know he'd be a great craven
ooh uh your friend
he's like who's my friend yeah i'm
trying to think guy plays aquaman
oh mamoa he looks exactly like [ __ ]
craven
he'd be an amazing [ __ ] crazy so tall
he's got that hair and [ __ ]
or joe magnum that's right joe me joey
maganello could be [ __ ] uh craving as
well
and he was in a spider-man movie he
originally played flash thompson
oh he was the guy who spider-man fights
in the lunchroom and is like going like
that
on the punches and [ __ ] um all right
let's see uh
george dewitt 18 says hey guys i'm going
to be in red bank area around the secret
stash for work
since my new job has an office nearby
probably stop by
but any good food places or if you been
not i've not been around there in a long
time
um no i i we go frequently i haven't
been there in months though because of
the kovitz thing
last time i was there was uh during the
jane salabab reboot roadshow tour
um where could i suggest you eat well if
you wait a few weeks you can eat at
movies pop-up right there in red bank
you can eat uh regular hamburgers or
vegan hamburgers made with beyond
burgers and stuff
um but uh barring that let's see one of
my favorite places to eat it's not in
red bank proper
um but it's uh kind of closer it's the
long branch
is the uh inkwell the inkwell cafe
me and him been going there since we
were pups since we were little kids
me him brian johnson walt flamington it
was a place that was
open until like four in the morning not
a diner more like a coffee shop and [ __ ]
but they had a great
extensive menu it was run by this old
hippie guy
he sold it to this other guy who's been
running it for the last decade real
sweet dude and whatnot
um it's a mainstay of the jersey shore
for those that uh live there if you go
to monmouth university
you probably know it real well and stuff
they make this chicken salad grilled
chicken salad on a pita that's one of my
favorite things in the world but i'm
vegan now so i don't eat it and stuff
but
they added a whole vegan section to
their menu with the egg well they make
beyond burgers there as well green mill
windmill that's one of your faves well i
mean for that like classic uh
cheese fries and hot dogs and that's
right next to
uh inkwell as well but those are in long
brands think about red bank mr pizza
slice
um what's the sub joy i mean the the
taco joints right
surf taco right next to jane salam bob's
secret stash
well the daily girl's out here but
you're talking about the uh the broadway
grill yeah
yeah they're long gone also the the
diner's gone
but it's now something i think it's
called toast or something a purple egg
and cheese that's the first thing you
got to get for breakfast
yeah jersey kids we grew up particularly
low-rent jersey kids like us who weren't
raised by rich people
we ate pork roll egg and cheese man pork
roll some people call it taylor ham
it's a uh it's a lunch meat or a
breakfast lunch meat deli meat that's
you know kind of like here's a bunch of
[ __ ] left over from other meats and
whatnot
so uh they take it and uh you cut it in
circles they put it on the grill and it
bubbles up
creates this like little bubble of air
under it and you put it on with an
egg and some cheese and you put it on a
kaiser roll or a round roll
hard roll a little ketchup on that
[ __ ] if you're into it oh
good times but uh you could do a vegan
version of it too but
he ain't talking about that he talked
about the real deal but it's called pork
roll
not taylor ham it's a big jersey
difference
many people have lost their lives in
fights over
pork roller taylor ham but yeah a lot of
great places to eat
in red bank man what is the beer gardens
go to the beer garden man
beer vino i think it's called they used
to be called something else
uh basil teas but they make some of the
best
[ __ ] local jersey uh vegetables like
fresh
tomatoes and [ __ ] like that great pizza
great food over there beer vino that's
another place to try
um all right what else we got
good for you going to be george dewick
going to be in red bag not us
george dewitt we're looking up to him at
this point finally got a chance to see
jane salam bob reboot recently says rj
dude
so good jay my dude you got me emotional
in a few scenes wasn't he great
thank you really really great stuff iron
bob is [ __ ] awesome
uh also i just graduated university this
year majoring in screenwriting thanks in
large part to clerks and youtube goofs
rj dude go write your movie i look
forward to buying a ticket to see it man
um and if you need some people to be in
it
let's see banana boss says i love you
guys we love you too
the mind screwer says what are you two
looking forward to on fandom i want to
see that batman i want to see any batman
footage from matt reeves
i want to see any wonder woman footage
from patty jenkins
um what else do i want to see i want to
see some black adam stuff
i want them to announce who's playing
hawkman and i hope that it's
uh it's the dude from trueblood
skarsgard he played eric
the vampire um
what else do i want to see any news
they're going to give us about
the cw shows um
i'm there for all of it i'm ready i want
fandom to wash all over me and stuff
fandom
poor jay is blocked by the mic now not
anymore that was from before you fixed
it
um let's see what else we got damn right
look at this one looks like a [ __ ] go
down go uh looks like yeah up a little
bit more it looks like a kidnap note
keep going look at this g dayski i got a
movie idea if you credit me j
muse i got a movie idea you just wrote
it a lot wow that's very shining
like all work and no play makes jack a
dull boy
um he's got a movie hey i don't know if
you know this but he's got a movie idea
um you got any movie ideas yourself or
you just rely on your stupid friend to
make the movies
yeah kev what do you think of ed and
then it's gone
what are you looking for i'm trying to
what's up kevin love zach and mary make
a porno says tommy tsars
thank you tommy thank you tommy
um hey kids you in california are you
within driving distance of california
come see me and ralph garman do
hollywood babylon at the vineland
drive-in
on the big screen lots of cars everyone
beeping horns instead of laughing it's
gonna be a good time go to tickets
tickets at seasmod.com and then don't
forget if you're on the east coast
that utterly delicious movies is moving
to red bank
mid-september i'm gonna be there i'm
gonna have an event and stuff i said jay
you come and he goes [ __ ] no
he's scared of the kobe cat he's got a
kid and [ __ ] like that
i got a kid but she's all grown up so
i'm like i'm going out
i'm going to jersey i can't wait it's
been a long time
uh gem squad p.i says james i was too
shy to say this last time but i just
wanted to say
thank you and kevin smith for sharing
your account where you saved kevin smith
jay you're an amazing soul
and an incredible human being for saving
kevin such friends are rare
and come once in a lifetime i absolutely
love you too as a duo
kevin smith i don't know what i would do
without your excellent flicks oh man you
rock grim squad
um i really appreciate a jersey girl for
uh
doing something out of your norm thank
you keep rocking the world the way you
guys do
no wonder you're always streaming oh
yeah people always saying nice stuff man
i would never leave this room
i would just sit here and read all these
nice things and be like [ __ ] the rest of
the world
and if my daughter came and said daddy
play with me i'd be like no daddy's
reading messages
my wife came was like get in here and
have sex with me i'd be like no i'm
reading nice messages and stuff
i could see this how this is uh it's
awesome and again i got the same
it's awesome because the same like
there's a tight
uh community of like 300 that pop in
every day
oh i know it rooting me to try to win
fall guys
and they stay it they stay hard nang
the uh that's see you're you're
experiencing what i experienced
years ago for the first time back in
like 19 late 95
so 25 years ago when we opened up the
viewski website and we built a there was
a community we didn't try to it's just
people coalesced and suddenly there was
this little community
where you knew everyone's name and [ __ ]
you're like oh it's trey mark
and you could get in fights with people
because you're so familiar with them and
be like [ __ ] you that's wrong and [ __ ]
and then we would hold events and people
come so that's the next thing
when everyone's allowed to get back in
the world you get your [ __ ] stream
you do it live
and everybody shows up i want to do like
a zoom con or something where people can
come in
that makes sense keep an eye out i'm
going to do a 12 hour i'm going to do an
18-hour stream uh in the next like
six days 18 a soft go 24.
dj sellout 69.96 says j muse
hey kevin j huge huge fan
i finally went to the secret stash and i
loved it thank you
yes i'm going back again also i just
watched tusk the other day and i ordered
my statue of you and jay
i can't wait i'm so excited oh my god dj
sellout 69.96 you got one of them
sweet level 52 statues you saw those
right
yes yeah we showed it last time here so
i got it that's expensive well done man
you guys are gonna get to see behind the
scenes if kevin will do it
because i'm so excited my tick tock oh
got 100 almost 200 000 views
and five thousand likes but i wanna see
if me and you do it and you guys will
get to watch us do it
it's an easy one what is the tick tock
i'll show you well i'll show you mine
and logan's ready watch that's the one
that got 200 000 views
yeah it's got 10 000 likes now i'm so
excited wait why
all right you're going to see me and jay
tick talking live
so it's wind tunnel but like 10 000
likes so anyway i want me and you to do
the same thing so it's easy watch we go
back
okay i'm gonna learn how to tick-tock
look at how many [ __ ] tic-tac videos
you got
um i don't have that many actually i saw
at least nine
yeah yeah but they're basic because i
don't know how to do it i only got one
uh wait let me see that
uh sounds guys you're gonna see this uh
uh what's the song
it's called this is what i would oh
there it is i think that's it i hope
it took me a while to find it before
yeah but
we're about to tick-tock and i'm gonna
get this going you're about to
watch it behind the scenes you're about
to see the tick-tock man
it's gonna happen in front of you have
you ever said said to yourself this
tick-tock intrigues me but
i don't know if i can do it you're about
to see jay do it and i'm about to learn
too
shane geeklylab says geeklygab says oh
my god hollywood babylon is the best
kevin inspired me to podcast that been
since 2016. thank you
isn't podcasting fun uh do it those who
podcast know
know the freedom of self-expression all
right we ready yup we're ready we're
about to [ __ ] tick-tock now what do i
do you go so when i point when it goes
ah
yeah i'll put it on you and you just
gotta if you just open your mouth watch
yeah do that ready okay so i'm gonna
start ready yes
perfect
nice
[Laughter]
[Music]
nice and with that two very old men
have tick-tocked we have tick-tock we
have tick-tocked
in the past tense ladies and gentlemen
now i just got to make sure i save it
but i want to write stuff
on it but you guys don't have to keep
listening to it all right treymok says
and uh we can't back this scientifically
it seems like an opinion
trademark says pretty sure pork roll
cures covet
yes oh my god if it did he'd never get
coveted
he would have been covered proofed since
he was a child man this [ __ ]
will take pork roll blend it up and
drink it through straw he likes it so
much
but i like also it's like it usually
comes on a kaiser roll which is amazing
pumpkin duchess says i found out today
i'm getting a promotion at work my best
friend and i have been watching you
since we were kids you make my day lots
of love
congratulations pumpkin duchess
it's coming up on pumpkin season pumpkin
spice season do you like you [ __ ] with
pumpkin spice
uh pumpkin spice psychic
[ __ ] do you remember remembering
clerks ii when uh
um earthquake and wanda sykes come into
the movies
and um you know uh [ __ ]
randall's in the kitchen he says
something about we saw this [ __ ] stain
we went to school with
and we cut over to wanda sykes and she
was [ __ ] stain what the [ __ ] a [ __ ]
stain
and uh and what was it uh earthquake
goes
oh white boys get white girls do
anything he goes he goes
you wanna do a [ __ ] stain we can cut
away
awesome it reminded me that because i
was i sounded like that delivery
um beth longo says they did a fantastic
job on these can't find panthor anywhere
you know where you will find panthor
beth longo
my masters of the universe miniseries oh
[ __ ]
spoilers last week we did this show
there people pulled news things is that
posted or is it just no no no because i
want to write like tags and stuff so
you're just saving it
yeah can you temporarily save it so
don't go out that's what i'm worried
about
do your tags and [ __ ] because otherwise
what if it goes away
that's some genius [ __ ] right there what
was it was the ripple effect called
a wind blow uh [ __ ] wind tunnel wind
tunnel
this tick tock is fun it might catch on
mike sparrow 87 says i want a battle cat
don't we all
uh coop gaming pwp
gaming says is my new name jay
we were pro wrestling power podcasts for
your info sir
pro wrestling power podcast that's his
new name jay
oh okay okay kevin are you gonna make
batman beyond happen
me i killed joy 13 30 you think i got
that kind of power
none whatsoever i'll tell you what i'm
going to do for batman beyond i'm going
to watch it
when it finally happens that's for darn
sure um
the other day you boys did an intro for
my assignment and i didn't get a chance
to say thanks so thanks man that's from
eyepiece you're welcome i remember that
when we introduced the thing stream labs
if you saw jay
sucking his finger in reboot and decided
what the
and decided you need some more you could
check out his tick-tock
j mario 78 says he's a big fan of kevin
smith
i am live i've know i am i've watched
all he's done except the truest thing
he made clerks the first thing he made
oh you haven't seen that yet
boy you're in for a disappointment no it
is fun movie look clerks
very inspiring it makes you go like [ __ ]
i want to make a movie too
that's the best kind of art man the kind
of art makes you want to make your own
art
um the king of alpaca you know what
alpaca is
oh well it's like a little uh llama oh
okay
the king of alpaca kevin smith do you
think your new movie will be shown in
russia
like the tusk and yo goes yoga hosers
went to russia
delighted to hear that or must i pirate
it to watch
in my native language um
i did reboot get to russia
can you pay some rubles for a reboot i
don't know if it made it there but i do
remember tusk making it there
because i saw the poster and i was like
wow um we got a russian audience
this is crazy it's really something that
i hadn't
thought about and i guess it makes sense
because the very first movie clerks
had olaf in it it was like this is his
russian metalhead because
silent bob could go to russia and people
would be like
oh my love for you is like truck belzer
you know what i'm saying like i had no
idea that like we've
we've had like a russian following going
all the way back to clarity
i've never been to russia yeah no we
have uh i have a girl who's on here all
the time uh
novo comes on uh and she's russian
yeah she's in russia and there's a bunch
of people from australia finland
scotland
uh romania spain
barcelona barcelona i've been there i've
been to spain but i mean it says
barcelona but they pronounce it
bartholomew
the c becomes a th i've also been to
valencia and uh
where's i've been to a few places in
spain but yeah i've never been to russia
how many russians we got here man any
russians popping up aside from my man
kevin smith dr gonzo says you remind me
of my late cousin brother and reminds me
of him every time i see you on screen so
thanks for just being you sir
that's you're gonna make me cry man that
[ __ ] means the world
thank you for that um if seeing me
brings up good memories
i'm here for you eggs blake says the
russians love olaf lady t
1180s is global
that made me laugh um
let's see what else we got my love for
you is like a truck bill zucker
saratov 81 says russians love you guys
i'm from russia
sergio sima says in soviet russia
bob silences you that's a as a
yakov smirnoff joke um church 1122 said
holy hell who knew yoga hosers made it
to russia
yeah me neither i didn't know um
musin says kevin you got an audience in
every country in the world
i mean i guess the small one depending
on what territory but for some reason it
never occurred to me
that russia would be part of it but why
you know it but now looking back i guess
it kind of makes
like sense to some degree um it's like
russia and asia i never
like would think yeah and i should have
thought like russia before
asia but i've been to asia like there's
jay and sam bob strike back and clerks
came out in japan i was over there for
the opening of jay and silent bob
strike back years ago um and it's not a
huge following but like
it's there and also when tusk came out
they had this big
japanese like section of downtown like
fully decorated tusks looked like they
spent some money
um but yeah i'm always surprised when
any place that's not america
england or australia says
oh we know your stuff and like your
stuff it's very flattering and um
wonderful but for some reason i never
thought about
like the russian angle um all this time
all this time i've never we've never
been over there
could you imagine we might we might be
like like kings of russia
we might be more popular than putin in
russia for all we know
like hundreds
um we could be premiers
russian premiers back in the 90s i was
working in a video rental store the
manager gave me a screener of clerk says
warlock of wi-fi
and i fell in love i took it to dragon
con and got you and scott to sign it
i remember that dragon con is the only
one i've ever been to in 1996.
uh sadly an ex-girlfriend kept it and i
never saw it again
no lol he says um
hyperbog says will we find out if he
came or what in the mall rat sequel
that's funny
from like uh well did he come about
jesus christ there's some things you
don't talk about in public
originally from manalapan new jersey
says casually cosplaying
but living in nashville now wow man
that's far away
jersey represent hope to see you guys
back in nashville after all this
where's the place we go to the comedy
club in nashville that we've been to
many times zany's what a great place i
think it's zany's yeah i'm pretty sure
it says that's where
um we've done [ __ ] get old we've done
i think babel was there i've done q and
a's there
um yeah i like
nashville's wonderful town last time one
of the last times i was there i went
um walking like in the district where
they got all the honky tonks
that main street right there where it's
like literally honky tonk after honky
tonk
i couldn't understand how like since
they're right next to each other and all
playing music
at full [ __ ] tilt loud how you can
compete right like if you're in one
place aren't you gonna hear the piano in
the other place but they didn't
it's pretty amazing a lot of music as
you walk down the street plays alive
with [ __ ] music
not you know the kind of music that you
and i are into but music nonetheless
um can't play games on here will kev
play any more games on here get him to
play fall
guys but i think he's scared i'm not
scared um found to be missing says kevin
any chance you could talk to the dudes
at movies for the next pop-up i'm
allergic to bread and they couldn't sell
me a burger without a bun is that right
wow that's well i guess because we're
not yeah i was gonna say like what do
you mean without a bun
since we're since you couldn't sit in
the restaurant and eat it was all pickup
so they they couldn't just make a burger
and then
wrap it in something because everything
was wrapped and stuff so i could see
where that might have stymied them
um i can ask them that's more of a
eat-in
experience i think to be like can you
leave this off um
just because i think they were at a
impasse as to how to wrap a burger
without the bread yes but then how to
wrap that as well
you know i'm making excuses i don't even
know yes give me all the lettuce so i
may wrap this burger
but i will put in a word for uh those
who are gluten challenged and just don't
want to [ __ ] with bread
um but i think that had more to do with
the fact that it was take out
throughout its whole life out here in
los angeles but i'll see if in jersey
it could be different um
philadelphia philadelphia fun name
kevin what'd you think about the doom
patrol adaptation i think it was a fresh
new take and i hope dc does more of it
are you talking about the comic book or
the tv show
um both wonderful takes doom patrol is a
fantastic uh
franchise and been around for a while
better you know older than the x-men and
they
they look a awful lot like the x-men um
so i loved grant morrison's incarnation
back in the day
um and i was so happy to see them do the
tv show it plays very
true to the spirit anarchic spirit of
the book
even to they have flex mental oh in it i
mean that's crazy
um let's see what inspired you to become
a filmmaker says
chief chief 420 and i also love your
quote at the end of clerks it's my
favorite quote nah
what like most women uh
most women don't make it lasagna at work
or most most women just cheating on you
or something
um you know there's a million fine
looking women in the world but not all
of them bringing lasagna to work most of
them just cheat on you that was the
inside of a [ __ ] 23 year old kevin
smith that was my perspective back then
because i'd been cheated on once
and so that's why silent bob says what
silent bob says
um but anyway what inspired me to become
a filmmaker i saw richard linklater's
film slacker on my 21st birthday
and it made me want to be a filmmaker
and uh for years
before i'd wanted to be a filmmaker i
would see this kid because we were
friends
and i'd be like somebody should put
you're in a movie you're so [ __ ]
funny man you're funny you're talented
somebody should put you in a movie one
day
and then that one day that someone was
me and i was right
look here we are doing this um
please film 26 episodes vajay and sambob
tv series
i i don't know if that's possible the
king of alpaca
says kevin j and simon bob movie is kind
of iconic in russia
strike back really
i like it why i like it i can see the
new one being iconic in russia because
it's like
there's a russian agent in it and stuff
like that but
i yeah that's crazy um kevin on
kevin on chinese tick tock and has
russian followers says 12
tc fbi coming you know
who knows um barcelona
says m fly 1229 see she knows what i'm
talking about
uh groovy mr drizzle has a question for
you jay he says would you like to suck
his [ __ ]
belzerk would you like to make some [ __ ]
yeah um
squat box is seriously why i reached out
so heartfelt with our girls recent heart
issues
we became even more connected with kevin
the reboot was emotional in the best way
y'all inspire us to keep smiling even on
the hard days i'm a full-time
law student shooting for a master's in
human rights
and health care law holy [ __ ] that's
heroic work
that's how you be batman without
punching anyone in the face spoiled
rotten 79
is and is motivational speaking uh to
the next level oh that's beautiful
well done man like they got some trial
in their lives dealing with their girls
heart issues and still they're like
moving forward and making a life uh for
their family man that's
that's america that's the world son that
ain't just america that's everybody
we're all alike in that way i know
people always like to pit us against one
another and whatnot but everybody just
trying to do the same thing man
make it through trials and tribulations
so they can make a life for themselves
and their family that
you know every morning they wake up and
look forward to living as opposed to
some kind of life where people are
always tired or like i don't like this
and stuff and right now
during covert with everybody in
quarantine and a lot of people who are
kind of sad because
some people can't deal with being
isolated and whatnot we're lucky
because we're married no we're lucky
because we're we are married and we have
separate families and stuff like that
so we're surrounded by people so if
you're not surrounded by people
if this is sometimes a tether for the
real world for you well then you just
keep coming on twitch every day and
watching jay for heaven's sakes man we
ain't leaving anybody behind heaven's
sakes
um mike sparrow 87 says i'm from about
botswana and i know you have an audience
in southern africa
the [ __ ] he's from botswana
south africa man he goes i know you have
an audience that's crazy
um sweden says bonanista
and that's it is not from sweden
are they he she boy girl do you know she
she right yeah bonus are you from sweden
number two two in the gift babe i
thought i thought uh
she was right here in america oh i
thought i thought so as well have you
ever thought about doing a watch party
on twitch where you can watch
any amazon movie or tv show
stream can watch as well yeah we at the
beginning of the quarantine i did a job
reboot watch along
we should do one together me and him
maybe next week because it's amazon
twitch all the same family yeah yeah
amazon prime has reboot so maybe we'll
watch reboot and we'll do a running
commentary and [ __ ] that'd be fun but
we should do more of them tick tocks
yeah i want to do more tick tocks we're
going to do more tick tocks
go to our tic tacs also uh you know how
sad like look at these
old [ __ ] middle-aged men are like
we're gonna do some tick tocks
we got a tick tock baby we're young
old um yeah we're gonna tick-tock it
until people are like
[ __ ] suck my tick-tock get out
there's a bunch of people
there's two girls that do uh only tick
tocks as jm bob
are you serious yeah yeah and there's
another guy we should do it with them
let's get on their tick tock i think you
could do duos with people too
really yeah um the lamp
the clamp nambler
says my cat had two kittens that
survived the other day and i named them
jay and silent bob
yes sad for the kittens that we lost
happy to have kittens named after us man
congratulations
uh matt westfalen who we all know and
love says so pumped about your he-man
revelations prequel comic
as well as the revelations toy line any
news regarding the prequel comic release
date so
uh we're doing a prequel comic that ties
into
masters of the universe uh revelations
our series
um what can i tell you well we uh just
we looked at a bunch of artists and
picked one
uh today so we're gonna see if that
artist is free to be able to work on our
book
uh me and rob david gonna be working on
that book
let's see man rob david is amazing great
guy
he wrote the master universe dc comics
for the last
few years not the most recent run of
books but like uh
the attorney of war books if i remember
correctly
um musin says kev if you got the chance
to offer my condolences to the family
and loved ones of lisa it broke my heart
when i found out we lost her
yeah lisa spoonhour uh died was two
years ago
so young far too young um lisa played
caitlyn
in clerks uh for a time she was married
to jeff anderson who played randall
in clerks they met while we were making
the movie and then they got married
after that they were together for a few
years
they split up and remained great friends
and stuff it wasn't like a bad
breakup or whatever but lisa uh was a
girl that i walked up to
cold after watching her in a class an
acting class at brookdale community
college i was sitting in the back and i
just sat in on an acting class because i
needed a caitlyn we had our dante we had
our randall we had veronica we had jay
and i didn't have a caitlyn so i go to
brookdale community college i sit in the
back of this acting class
and of everyone acting lisa i didn't
know her name but there's this one girl
who was like really natural and
authentic
so after the class i walked up to her in
the parking lot which must be the
[ __ ] terrifying notion for any woman
some strange man coming up to you and be
like and i was like you want to be
you're really good actress you want to
be in a movie
i said i'm making a movie you want to be
in it and i remember lisa was like what
like a porn
and i was like no it's not a porn it's
an independent
film independent film like people hadn't
heard of that where we were from at that
point
so i said i got a script you could read
it and she's like all right give me the
script and i gave her a script and phone
number to contact
she must have thought it was like the
most ham-fisted pickup line in history
but it wasn't it was literally about
being in the movie and so then she
called me after she read and she goes
this is funny
i would do this i would do this and i
was like right on come meet with us when
we're doing
uh these rehearsals and [ __ ] and boom we
had our caitlyn
so um she passed away i think it was two
years
ago at this point um
you know and she had had i think for a
little while a complicated relationship
with the movie she told me on facebook
at one point
that for years she like didn't you know
she was like ugh
that clerks thing i did ugh
years later she she was talking about
she'd gotten sick
at one point before she passed away
and there was a boy online i don't
remember his name
um but he reached out to her from
facebook and he was from someplace else
not from jersey he could have been from
another country for all i remember
and he asked her like hey would you meet
me at
like quick stop and you know i'm a big
fan coming over
from some other place and so lisa said
that she was like you know i normally
don't
do that but you know this guy was making
a long trip
and and lisa had a daughter still does
and her daughter was young at this point
and so i think there was a sense of like
oh you know that was a part of my life
and how weird that this kid from some
other place is coming all the way to new
jersey to see the
quick stop so i i'll accommodate him and
she came out
and took pictures with him and talked to
him and stuff and took him around to all
the places where we shot
the movie and she um
she said that like through that
person she was able to
like put clerks in a different
perspective
and it made her happy you know she had
gone through some really bad health
issues and
suddenly talking to this kid about
clerks and
seeing the interaction with him and
others on facebook
like she couldn't believe it she was
like god people really
loved that movie and like she was
she likes felt this weird sense of
pride like after years of kind of being
like oh [ __ ] clerks
she had gotten to a place where she was
like wow clerks was
was this really magical thing and that
was given to her by a fan
i'm sorry i'm getting emotional um
so for as many people like you know who
are like
wow you guys give us this and the movies
and blah blah blah
one of you gave lisa an appreciation for
this
thing that she had done which she
dismissed
earlier in life as just like a fluke and
then come to realize that
it was something important and magical
and meant something to a lot of people
you know some of us
i guess i always understood and
appreciated what clarks meant to people
but maybe some people were like too
close maybe she didn't
see it you know but she did see it later
in life
through a fan showed it to her and stuff
so she had that
like before she passed away um
and it it seemed to mean a lot to her
like our facebook
exchanges were primarily about that
about she's like the people that love
these movies she's going they're really
sweet
and like they're they're caring and like
they say amazing things
and so she passed away as previously
mentioned
at a very young age leaving behind a
daughter
um and
uh we miss her naturally but i always
thought it was great that she
she somebody gave clerks back to her
you know as a gift when we made it she
was happy to do it and stuff and then
after the movie like came out she had
kind of a complicated relationship with
it for a little while
and then years later she found her way
back to the movie and saw it in a
completely
different light and i'm so thankful
that she had that before she left
because she was such
an important part of that movie and
it was nice just she got to realize how
important
she was and it was and her role in it
and
so anyway yeah i miss her it's a bummer
i don't i don't you know i
sent flowers to her family when she
passed and whatnot
um but i told jeff that when we make
clerks three we gotta put lisa's
daughter in it because that'll
because then we'll all be back to some
degree
um yeah so anyway
sorry uh let's get a nice one well i
mean it's not like that wasn't nice that
was really nice but let's get one where
i'm not gonna be all
emotional uh so i could get out of here
and give jay back his channel before
people start jumping off because like i
don't want to watch this [ __ ]
cry
clive klopp says i used to be compared
to john's tables
oh i needed that i know you didn't mean
it that way but that just seems like the
weirdest like conversation break
like you know when i was a young man
i used to be compared to john stamos
when i was a young man that compared me
to john amos
uh uh james james senior from good
[Music]
what do you mean i worked at john amos
bro did you and shelly long
yeah in that movie yeah you have screen
time with james senior yes
yes you got to understand like we were
kids that grew up on good times
i loved good times and james senior
was like a dad that i didn't have i
loved my dad don't get me wrong
but james senior was the traditional tv
dad who was also always threatening his
kids with violence
where he was always just like i'll take
you out and stuff like that always like
threatening jj and stuff
so i love james senior remember when he
dies and good times
he died and then like florida his wife
keeps it together all through the
[ __ ] funeral and [ __ ] and everyone's
trying to help her out clean up and
she's just keeping it light and
she you know she's not seriously
affected by his death that you can see
thus far
and then like everybody leaves so they
have the reception at the house the
after
party and [ __ ] and not the house
department and everyone leaves so it's
just her and the kids
and she's like well i guess i better
clean up and she's just functioning
in the house just cleaning up as if
nothing happened and the kids are like
mom you all right
and she's like i'm fine they're like mom
we can help you with that and she's like
i don't need help jj like she'd get real
tense about it she's like i want you to
just all
go away and they all go into the rooms
and stuff she's by herself
and she's trying to clean the kitchen
and she's moving a dish from the one
table to the
to the sink and also she just [ __ ]
throws it on the ground and shatters and
she goes
damn damn damn and she starts crying it
was such an emotional [ __ ] episode
[ __ ] you worked with john amos yes sir
was a cool guy
yeah it was really cool and i know james
senior remember the line in vulgar where
you have the line jay has the line in
vulgar in the movie that brian johnson
made where he's talking about some dude
he goes
he's got the body of james jr but the
muscles of james
senior
[Music]
um that [ __ ] that john stamos line
killed me that was [ __ ] that was the
perfect thing to pull me out of that man
you know when i was young
people looked like john's statements
someone just said he was he was also a
kunta kinte
who john stamos johnny well john amos
yeah not john stamos
john amos i think he was in roots yeah
yeah yeah
he might oh did he play the older kunta
kinte maybe
so he played the older version of um
reading rainbow because he played kunta
kente uh what's his name
you know from [ __ ] star trek oh my
god have i smoked the name away
somebody tell me uh jordy laforge's name
name on star trek levar burton thank you
fast kgb jesus
everyone two zags lavar bird lavar bird
lavar everybody's on it
i smoked it away for temporary so wait
what you're saying and you could be
right
um i don't know if i'm right they could
be right lavar burton was the young
coot's kids
and john amos played the older version i
guess they said right i met the
barbarian
dude's pretty chill um you blanked on
levar burton
nerd crew card revoked says junkyard
grizzly i know
please don't spread that around you get
clive cop's new one i got the body
i got the body of chris farley but the
smile of chris hemsworth to be honest
[Laughter]
one man's just is that the same dude a
man just having these reflections about
his life and he's just like
back in the days i was a king when they
thought i looked like stamos
why not me um
let me see kunta kente toby
grid master 420 yeah that was his the
that was his real name is kudz kintay
but then they tried to give him the name
toby um lol
touche says atl
bob uh ori leilu
says my husband claims he's homeless
thor look alike
um what is this luke luka beshear our
series
is about oh are they the ones who were
making the movie and everyone was saying
like don't do it yeah yeah
so follow up luke bashir
abshir says our series is about a
stalker in cell type who posts pov
videos online and people have thought
that the videos are real
holy [ __ ] so they're making a movie
about this guy who stalks people
and they put the videos online and
people like that's not a movie that's
for real
um we want to keep that up until the
series is over but the police want a
warning on every episode or two to take
them down um or every episode or to take
them down i understand
oh so there the police are like hey man
this is unnerving you got to put a
warning up that says
this is fake and obviously as the
filmmakers like we don't want to do that
we like
you know [ __ ] the illusion of reality
yeah that's a tough one
maybe i'd bury some sort of like uh
disclaimer in like the
description written description like in
parentheses this is fake or whatever the
[ __ ] but
putting it right up front man it kind of
ruins the effect
um extra terresticles
says niagara falls canada comic con
auction jay and sam bob figures was one
of the best-selling items
next to a signed stanley marvel poster
yes
[ __ ] good to know good to know if
america ever kicks us out russia
uh niagara falls spain these are all the
places that me and jay can relocate and
stuff that will wilkins says when i was
younger i was compared to john [ __ ]
um stuffy seath
seventhy stealthy but with the seven met
kevin once playing poker at the palms
he was deadpan and i was like why isn't
kevin smith emoting
but he was playing poker and he played
tight which is the smartest way to play
it's true when i played poker with jay
like and that's kind of why i stopped
like you know you're conversing and [ __ ]
and you're like
and then as soon as you sit down the
table you're like
and you gotta play poker face or else
people like start
what do they call it rounders man they
like take you and stuff
they see that you're a donkey um
drewhood2121 says could you say i'm
kevin smith and this is the hall of
justice
hi i'm kevin smith and this is the hall
of just
us
you two are [ __ ] legends dogma rats
still two of my favorite movies ever
says zelikai 77 why thank you
um here you go this might be the last
one this is a good one to go out on sir
jeff biscamp says kevin and jay
what is the best advice you could give
on how you individually get over
adversities
thanks bro ah how to get over adversity
you know how you get over adversity this
is how you get over adversity
crush your enemies see them driven
before you and hear the lamentation of
the women no that's conan those are the
what is best in life conan things um how
to get over adversity
how do i do it because i've had to do it
a bunch
um
i really you just kind of have no choice
like because either you quit the game
all together
or you pick up and you go back at it
like you know yeah it was it was tough
after mall rats we made mall rats and
now people love mall rats but when it
came out people [ __ ] on it made no money
and stuff
and you know you're like oh my god how
do i go on but
you pick up you try again we fail that's
it's inevitable that we fail you know
even steven spielberg has had a movie
that
didn't quite work the way he wanted to
um you know and just in life in general
sometimes you hit a wall um how do you
deal with it
sometimes a little bit of self-care
sometimes you got to go off lick your
wounds
like oh man [ __ ] didn't work out the way
i wanted but then
repurpose and go at it again you can't
sit around lick your wounds forever and
complain and [ __ ] and [ __ ] like that
you get a day
something disappointing happens you know
give yourself a day be like [ __ ]
um don't take it out on others just be
frustrated but
i'm down you can totally do a florida
evans right there damn
damn damn but i find that being creative
like gets rid of negativity you fight
destruction with creation so
you know getting over adversity start a
new thing
doesn't mean like record a podcast make
a movie not everyone does that
just start a new thing a new project
like you know i always wanted to clean
my closet i'm gonna [ __ ] do that this
week
creation the act of creation is the
antithesis of destruction
so at that point your mindset's
completely changed
you're kind of moving past adversity
i've found
so be creative whatever that is to you
like jay likes to make legos he calls
that creative and [ __ ]
um i like to write or record a podcast
some people like to cook and take
pictures of it put it on
instagram it's unessential [ __ ]
inessential nonsense that like you know
people be like well you don't have to do
that of course not
but the things we don't have to do in
life the things those are the things we
want to do the fun
things like you know you don't have to
do it you want to do it because it's its
own joyful thing to do
so get over adversity by just making a
thing
you know creating taking on a new
project
not saying like leave that other project
and also if you want to improve upon
the thing that failed or you gave you
adversity because it was a project you
were working on it didn't work out
put it to the side maybe work on
something else then come back to it
never abandon it all together man
um never let the work finish you you
finish the work
you got that you like that i like it put
on a [ __ ] t-shirt and a bumper
sticker
copyright trademark kev smith um thank
you for hanging out with us i'm leaving
but i assume he's gonna do this until
one in the [ __ ] morning and [ __ ] um
but boy oh boy
we had a good time taking out knives and
[ __ ] stabbing boxes and looking at
cool ass
masters the universe figures thank you
to the good folks at mattel
for giving a [ __ ] to open jay will be
playing a marble game with you later on
and giving away those gifts and when
luke is done
selfishly getting married to his new
wife luke will come home and send you
those gifts including
the hound head which treymok has been
waiting on after disappointment after
disappointment a broken iron bob
busted movie meal kit he's just waiting
for that hound head to make it all right
tell you what i'm gonna put julian on
that i bet you i'm gonna see julian
after this i'm gonna be like send the
man's hound head out
he needs it it's trey mock for christ's
sakes um
thanks for being here thanks for hanging
out i'm gonna get the [ __ ] out of here
go home and [ __ ] don't forget
hollywood babylon ladies and gentlemen
the 10th anniversary show is at a
drive-in
out here monday night in vineland the
vineland drive-in in
city of industry out here in california
come watch me and ralph from the safety
of your car
man smoke up in the safety of your car
as you watch
hollywood babylon under the stars on the
big screen and [ __ ]
if this goes well guess who's next
jane silly bob good old 10th anniversary
show and that kevin smith club check
that out yeah go to that kevin smith
club and check that [ __ ] out join if you
will
check out my tick tock our tick tock
we're going to do tick tocks
he's he just put up a tick tock and [ __ ]
like that look at him he's keeping busy
you want to keep him off drugs how long
have you been off drugs ten years two
months you wanna keep them off [ __ ]
look at that ten years and two months
keep him off drugs by keeping him busy
here
in his little bat cave and whatnot with
all his monitors you want a cameo
no i'm just kidding yeah you want a
cameo go to what is your camera i know
what it is jmu's probably same thing
j-a-y-m-e-w-s
um we're doing a cameo thing because i
did a cameo and we raised money for
uh the naacp empowerment fund
but um we're going to do the homemade
cameo thing called
cavio go to cavio.com k-e-v-e-e-e-o
dot com and uh they're gonna have uh
josh and liv
who shoot waka bakes and they toured
with us our tour managers
uh they're making a movie called uh
wrong reasons and so
to raise a portion of uh the budget
we're doing
homemade cameos so you can we can shoot
them and send them to josh is doing it
every single penny goes right into the
production and stuff so look for that
we'll be announcing that soon
as well in the meantime i return you to
your regularly scheduled program already
in progress
the great jason muse but for jane sound
bob get twitchy i'm kevin smith jason
go get twitchy [ __ ] um all
right
yeah i'm gonna i do what i always do i'm
gonna put on a video real quick
um and then i'm gonna walk kevin to his
car
and i'll be back i need a walk to my car
it's dangerous out there
dangerously hot i might pass out all
right where's my
kids i'm out of liquids
that's a fun graphic all right look at
that who did that
i want to do a shirt uh the guys who
made this video
do you know jay has been on twitch over
a year now
oh that was when uh i got the footprints
yeah and you got footprints too
look at that video man that's fun
oh my god
you